CBS News correspondent Omar Villafranca
has been covering this tragedy since the
very beginning and he joins me now with
more on how this all happened in Omar
there's still so many questions from
people around here and who know about
this story
good morning and there is and the NTSB
started their investigation it will take
months to exactly find out what happened
but of course family members they want
answers right now and survivors of this
horrible tragedy are now starting to
speak out and I was yelling and I was
screaming
and finally I say Lord just let me die
let me die I said I can't I can't keep
drowning 31 people were on board the
duck boat that capsized trying to reach
the shores of Table Rock Lake on
Thursday
Tia Coleman was one of the 14 survivors
two people said Jesus please kick me
just keep me so I can give him my
children gave me Lord Coleman made it
back safely along with her nephew but
nine other family members from Indiana
including her three children died in the
water our investigation is comprehensive
we'll look at the vessel we'll look at
the operation of the vessel we'll look
at the people involved look at the
environment a severe thunderstorm watch
had been in effect for the area since
11:20 a.m. Thursday morning the tour
began early Thursday evening at 6:32
p.m. about 40 minutes before the boat
sank the National Weather Service issued
a severe thunderstorm warning and said
winds could gust to 70 miles per hour
witnesses say the weather changed from
sunny to stormy in a matter of minutes
the winds were so strong it bent street
signs should that boat have been on the
water well I think yes at the time with
what we knew then when we knew it it was
calm water Jim Patterson jr. is
president of Ripley entertainment the
company purchased Ride the Ducks in
Branson six months ago do you know what
you're gonna tell your the families just
what can you say you know we're so sorry
anytime that people suffer a loss like
that
it'd take camp every place 17 people
died on the boat the victims include its
driver Bob Williams along with Janice
and William bright who are celebrating
their 45th wedding anniversary
William brights sister Karen Abbott
spoke to the Kansas City Star on Friday
I think this company should have their
ass suit off of them and every penny
they have made should be returned to
every victim that's ever lost their
lives in this Tia Coleman said
passengers were told where the life
jackets were located but that they
wouldn't be needed I thought at some
point he would say grab the jackets now
but we were told to stay seated and
everybody stays seated duck boats by law
are required to carry lifejackets but
passengers are not required to wear them
and Dana the boat sunk in about 80 feet
of water it was so close to the shore we
could see the divers where they were
they could see the shoreline they hope
to have that boat out of the water by
Monday yeah when you looked at the
pictures you thought why can't they get
to shore that's how close it looked Oh
Maura thank you very much